[Música]
eu gostaria de começar fazer uma breve
reflexão de tudo o que a humanidade
passou para chegar exatamente onde a
gente está agora a espécie humana com a
gente conhece surgiu há cerca de 150 mil
anos atrás eram os pequenos grupos de
caçadores e coletores que ficamos o
tempo inteiro andando em busca do que
comer e onde morar
algum tempo depois nós evoluímos nós
dominamos a caça ea agricultura e assim
conseguimos nos estabelecer no mesmo
lugar por mais tempo
foi nesse momento que surgiram as
primeiras cidades e civilizações
por volta de 400 anos antes de cristo
sugiro aqueles que são conhecidos como
alguns dos maiores filósofos da história
sócrates aristóteles e platão um deles
matam criou a primeira escola do mundo
academia de platão e objetivo dessa
escola era preparar e preparar membros
do clero e da nobreza preocupar posições
importantes no futuro ou seja era uma
escola extremamente elitizado por volta
de 1760 aconteceu a primeira revolução
industrial
ela foi marcada pelos de máquinas no
processo produtivo
os produtos que antes eram fez de
maneira artesanal na casa das pessoas
começaram a ser feitos em fábricas
dentro de linhas de montagens com
auxílio de máquinas
a primeira revolução industrial tanto
transformou completamente nossa
sociedade
o comércio à disposição das cidades e
praticamente tudo em torno das pessoas
daquela época
a primeira revolução industrial também
foi a primeira vez que a escola mudou
seu propósito ela deixou de atender às
necessidades da elite da sociedade e
começou a atender à demanda crescente de
mão de obra para as fábricas naquela
época então o objetivo da da da escola
se tornou a formação em massa de
operários para trabalhar nas linhas de
montagem
algum tempo depois aconteceu a segunda
revolução industrial
ou seja ainda mais máquinas dentro do
processo produtivo
foi nesse momento que surjam tecnologias
como navios de ferro aviões e toda
indústria química e de motores que a
gente conhece hoje entre a década de 50
e o ano 2000 surgiu que é considerado
como logo depois do fogo a maior
descoberta a maior invenção da
humanidade à internet a internet os
computadores marcaram a terceira
revolução industrial e terceira
revolução industrial ou transformação
digital
as tarefas de uma linha de montagem que
antes eram feitas por máquinas que eram
operados por humanos começando a dar
certo a ser mais automatizadas sendo
feitas completamente por computadores na
internet como a gente sabe
mudou o mundo mudou nossa relação de
comunicação comércio transporte e
basicamente tudo nas nossas vidas nos
últimos 8 99 anos estamos vivendo a
quarta revolução industrial a chamada
indústria 4.0 é marcada pela lógica de
escala
estamos na estamos na era da
inteligência da inteligência artificial
na era da computação quântica
estamos na era onde a máquina vai roubar
o seu trabalho mas também é o primeiro
momento que pela primeira vez mais de
metade da população mundial tem acesso à
internet
isso significa que qualquer pessoa
consegue obter informação a um clique um
toque de distância bem com essa verba de
passagem pela nossa história dá pra ver
que muita coisa mudou para a gente
chegar onde a gente está hoje a
sociedade foi então foi transformada
várias vezes e que essas mudanças vão
ficando cada vez mais rápidas mas eu
tenho certeza que o unc uma coisa que
muitos aqui passaram alguns inclusive
estão passando é a mesma desde a
primeira revolução industrial
a escola a escola era como uma fábrica
de uma pessoa que falava o que tiver de
ser feito e como devia ser feito
geralmente as outras pessoas estão
uniformizados existiam sinais sonoros
que falaram que a pessoa que e eu fazer
alguma coisa diferente ou ea trocar de
turno existiam avaliações formais
trabalha pra variar
avaliar a capacidade das pessoas de
produzir em determinada tarefa
hoje a escola é a mesma coisa que um
professor que fica na frente falando uma
duas horas sem parar
o aluno quando ele está prestando
atenção o que ele faz é interpretar e
memorizar tudo que o professor fala e
quando chega a hora da prova ele
simplesmente reproduz tudo aquilo que
ele conseguir memorizar
é como se a 2010 o livro de receita logo
no início da sua vida e falasse olha
esse aqui é o que você precisa ter para
ter sucesso
o que você tem que fazer agora é esse
livro inteiro decorar todas as receitas
e quando alguém te pedi pra fazer um
prato
você simplesmente executar aquilo que já
está na sua cabeça
e acredite isso vai garantir parte
garante sucesso pra sempre bem
hoje a gente sabe que as coisas não
funcionam mas assim o prato que você vai
precisar de fazer amanhã talvez não
esteja no livro de receita que você
ganhou 15 anos atrás alguns ingredientes
mudaram foram substituídos por outros
melhores então se praticamente tudo no
nosso mundo foi atualizado várias e
várias vezes nos últimos séculos porque
a escola continua a mesma de 200 anos
atrás eu já vi muitas pessoas falam
sobre isso professores artistas
palestrantes
isso sempre me incomodou sempre que eu
estava dentro da sala de aula se sentia
preso lá e completamente impotente fazer
qualquer coisa ficava preso até que
decidi fazer alguma coisa
e foi assim que eu decidi que a minha
própria escola uma escola livre de
verdade onde os alunos aprendem uns com
os outros
onde não existem provas formais que
avaliam a capacidade do aluno de
memorizar uma grande quantidade de
informações sobre determinado assunto é
uma escola que nossa principal
preocupação é desenvolver as habilidades
comportamentais a soft skills dos alunos
que estão no mercado de trabalho
valoriza cada vez mais por exemplo de
liderança gestão de equipes vendas e
compartilhamento do conhecimento
nossa preocupação não é formar
profissionais para ocuparem altos cargos
no mercado de trabalho mas sim preparar
pessoas que podem ocupar qualquer
posição profissão onde quer que seja
uma pesquisa famosa realizada pela onu
a cidade de oxford indica quais são
aquelas profissões que têm o maior e
menor risco de serem extintas no futuro
de um lado da lista a gente encontra
coisas como operador de caixa
telemarketing e motorista de trem
isso já tem data pra não existe mais na
outra ponta encontramos coisas como
neurocirurgiões babás terapeutas
ocupacionais engenheiros nucleares
embora algumas coisas da área de saúde e
de engenharia muito específica façam
sentido não será não serem substituídos
por robôs por enquanto o que chama a
atenção é que cada vez mais as
habilidades humanas estão sendo
valorizadas por que o robô pode até
dirigir seu carro contra uma casa no
futuro mas uma máquina nunca vai ser
melhor que uma pessoa para trocar a
frota para trocar a falar de uma criança
ou pra conversar com uma pessoa que não
está se sentindo bem
tem empatia com aquilo e depois fazer
com que uma pessoa se sinta melhor a
profissão de uma criança que tem aqui
dentro no ensino médio esse ano talvez
ainda nem exista quando ela tiver
terminado a graduação
então como é que a escola fala que
prepara o aluno para o mercado de
trabalho se na escola nem o aluno e
talvez ninguém saiba como vai ser a
realidade do mercado no futuro talvez
não faça mais sentido nós perdemos três
quatro e cinco anos logo no início das
nossas vidas desenvolvendo a capacidade
de interpretar memorizar e reproduzir
informação sobre determinado assunto
talvez dê autonomia do aprendizado é o
que vai fazer você ter sucesso no futuro
para a maioria das pessoas é mais fácil
por exemplo aprender programação do que
conseguisse lidar bem com conflitos
dentro de uma equipe
se hoje eu consigo analisar o relatório
financeiro de uma empresa listada na
bolsa
amanhã eu aprenda a fazer um prato
exótico da culinária tailandesa
ao fazer um reparo na substância no meu
carro que está fazendo barulho estranho
nessa escola que chama marvin
a gente acredita que a maneira mais
autêntica do aprendizado é a troca de
conhecimento entre duas partes
então ao invés de ter uma autoridade
detentora da verdade dado conhecimento
da verdade absoluta
os alunos aprendem uns com os outros
eles se organizam naturalmente em grupos
de pessoas que têm interesses em comum
que querem aprender sobre determinado
assunto
eles começam a desenvolver uma série de
desafios para desenvolver as habilidades
isso faz muito sentido porque a gente
fica muito mais feliz e confortável
fazendo coisas que a gente tem afinidade
com outras pessoas que têm os mesmos
interesses com a gente e da maneira com
que cada um se sente mais confortável
por causa dessa por causa dessa
aplicação a gente achava que o marvin
era sobre o aprendizado baseado em
projetos mas eu queria que vocês
fecharem os olhos e pensassem na vida de
vocês
quando foi que você aprender alguma
coisa de verdade quando foi que vocês
tiveram uma lição
a nossa resposta pra isso é bem simples
é falhando
porque quando a gente erra a gente tem
uma sensação tão ruim que a gente a
gente incorpora não reproduzir aquilo de
novo e assim que nós alunos trabalham
quando ele trabalhou no método
científico
quando eles recebem um grande desafio a
primeira coisa a se fazer é quebrar esse
desafio problemas menores como se fossem
parte de um quebra cabeça
a partir daí eles estudam cada uma
dessas peças e começa a elaborar a
hipóteses de como encaixar elas até que
eles tenham várias soluções e
eventualmente eles conseguem uma que dar
certo
repetindo esse processo várias vezes
eles chegam a cuba e chegou a solução do
desafio eles montam o quebra cabeça como
um todo
a figura do professor lá ela é essencial
mas ela é completamente diferente do que
existe hoje não são pessoas com 11 anos
de aprofundamento acadêmico ou décadas
de experiência no mercado naquilo
são pessoas que o principal papel é
guiar o aluno pelo oceano de informações
que a gente tem disponível hoje são
pessoas que quando recebe uma pergunta
muito complicada
eles falam simples eu não sei que a
gente sentar e aprender junto com essa
autonomia do conhecimento a capacidade
de obter informações de qualquer lugar
o aluno está preparado para me preocupar
qualquer posição no mercado de trabalho
do futuro e eu espero que com essa
filosofia de educação as pessoas mudem a
maneira com que elas se relacionam com o
aprendizado
e principalmente com a escola não
acabando com ela
muito pelo contrário o que o move se
propõe a fazer é repensar a única coisa
que é a mesma desde a revolução
industrial
nós atualizamos a sala de aula
eu fico muito feliz de fazer parte desse
movimento de educação junto com outras
iniciativas de educação alternativa
espero que cada vez mais as pessoas
entendam que a necessidade delas de
aprendizado não aprendizado profundo em
uma área específica que vai levar para a
vida inteira mas sim ser capaz de
aprender desaprender e reaprender
obrigado
[Música]